well financially I think people are very
confused by my narrative people think I
was handed I love when people troll me
he was handed I was kind of nothing I
don't own a wine library financially it
was the other way financially i gassed
my parents up
that's facts when in spent 14 years
never paid myself the impact that I had
on the business what I deserved
because I invested in the business and I
left the 34 with no money to my name but
emotionally they put me so on because I
thought I was unstoppable and
experientially like my dad put me on by
giving me autonomy to run a business so
with a crate right
[Music]
yeah so let's just do everything here at
7:00 and like they have me done by like
9:30 if someone wasn't raised in that
environment that self belief how does
one develop that for themselves
surrounding themselves by people that do
it for them
or consuming content that does it for
them panics reading people's skulls and
[ __ ] reframing the games their
[ __ ] mom told him they were loser I'm
telling a more winner I think I can now
market their mom their mom had a big
head start and a whole lot of like
emotional like [ __ ] physiological
advantages but guess what give me
[ __ ] 18 months of your time give me
two hours a day I'll make you realize
[ __ ] your mom and go do your thing
that's what I'm up to hey guys it's Gary
I say to myself I suck but I don't let
any of you say I suck
you know like subcultures can call
themselves a certain thing but nobody
else can
you can [ __ ] make fun of your brother
but if somebody else does you punch him
in the [ __ ] mouth that's how I think
about the creative process it's a very
interesting fine line like I'm gonna
hold myself accountable but that's me
with me you were actually the judge you
as a collective as number one me to
myself is number two a distant third
which I can't even hear is an individual
giving me feedback I think my game is
very reversed from everybody else's
creatively all of you is number one the
market I only care about you
[ __ ] as a collective so I'm
just putting out so it's the creative
strategic framework that I have that is
absolutely [ __ ] right
[Music]
I think you guys should build a media
company I don't think you should
advertise I think you should build
barstool instead of vaynermedia creative
output fundamentally I believe a decade
from now every company's gonna realize
they're in the publishing business
they're in the media business they'll be
thinking about their OTT you know the
Red Bulls and the Pepsi is got nobody
think about owning an OTT outright
I think our kind of company's not that
trillion levels yet on our way our gonna
be thinking about becoming the bar
stools and the refinery 29s or whatever
it may be
I think that's the that's the number one
thing I would invest in are you sitting
here really like the date right there
early
that's tremendous [ __ ] it's amazing
great job super pumped it's a great
piece of content I'm literally putting
the date a little earlier I think we'll
win that three-second Facebook game that
I care so much about other than that man
that was [ __ ] tremendous storytelling
that's me great to see you thank you
guys
[Music]
that's uh that's if there was strategy
behind that it wouldn't work it's Who I
am
so I was about to say I'm a CEO of a big
company I've got this profile but it's
not true when I was 22 years old and I
had nine employees at Wine Library and I
was trying to build this business if I
sat down with somebody for 15 minutes
even though I had a lot going on because
it seemed like a lot of time it was my a
lot just like they have they're a lot
you have your lot right I think I work
for somebody else and so when we sat
down you know whether it's somebody like
you that had some context for me before
and think it's really cool or some
people like right my CEOs got like fans
or something right like and sits down
like I'm in that meeting for that person
it's less about strategy it's about
thoughtfulness I'm thoughtful more than
that it's this crazy strategy
one added layer of like human psychology
in the current state then I think you're
tapping into fashion-wise all the powers
and restrictions it's why snapchat one
yeah I think one of the things you
should consider is only available from
like 2:00 a.m. to 6:00 a.m. like make it
impossible like I'm obsessed with
restrictions like only available 2 a.m.
to 6 a.m. like that's [ __ ] terrible
like no like that's the worst like but
but what exactly why it's right in my
opinion all the answers are in the know
all the answers and it's so authentic to
where your brains position I think
resources gonna run out I will say this
the high/low of influencers I think is
gonna be your pay dirt so to me the Holy
Grail is his GG and young baby date
she's just a real cool like bucket no no
little J's ridiculous no it look rough
young baby Tate right she's like an
Atlanta [ __ ] she wears like you know
she looks like she's Avril Lavigne
but she's black and she's like can
really sing and she's in Atlanta and
like she's 50 she's 15 months away from
you you know 21 savage putting her on a
feature and then you know 22 months from
now she's famous yeah and then I get to
recall that I mentioned her and be like
look how I was on before all of you
right she's at 14 for right now
[Music]
here's what's great about her I can have
no idea how you guys would filter
fashion that's where you know here's
what I know she's gonna be a big star
all right I'm gonna be late as [ __ ] hey
brother how are you dude happiness
happiness is the [ __ ] ROI not not
checking some arbitrary just back to the
delusion and ego thing that you and I
just talked about like knowing what
you're gonna do for the rest of your
life at 30 or being out of the house by
30 or having your [ __ ] together by 30 or
[ __ ] being married by 30 or having a
kid by 30 that's [ __ ] horseshit and
as long as you don't [ __ ] spend your
money on fancy [ __ ] on the outside right
as long as like you don't get a bit like
the keys like when you get a developer
job and you get paid 150 that you don't
live a lifestyle that's based on 150
that if you don't one then want to be a
cook and you can only make 78 you're
[ __ ] stuck and then you end up being a
developer for your whole life you know
you [ __ ] hate in it because you needed
to be able to pay your rent and your
[ __ ] lifestyle recently never needed
a fancy car or fancy apartment of fancy
clothes or fancy things or go to fancy
places was because I didn't yearn for
them and I definitely wasn't gonna do
them for somebody else
I think most people do [ __ ] for other
people I think most people buy the car
and the house for other people do some
people love the leather of a car or the
horsepower yes do some people like love
having a home that has nine rooms they
never use sure but you understand I
[Music]
think once you own your weaknesses and
once you tap into emotions you become
unstoppable
the reason I want to talk about all
these insecurities is once you own it it
goes completely the other way like I
mean it's the best it's like the eight
it's the last scene of eight mile right
like like I need you to talk about the
fact that you're scared shitless I need
hey bro I need you to understand the
reason you bought a Rolex is because you
think you needed to bang a check
[Music]